I think I own about 200 pairs of the Air
Force one I might have a color for every
outfit I'm not gonna lie I got a long
history with the Air Force one shoe
myself like the late 90s jay-z the
torque or the hard-knock life tour on
the tour one of the stops was
importantly you can't miss home like he
so at this time they're first once I
became very big in hip-hop culture so I
got this voucher and I just lost my mind
because this place was full of Air Force
Ones they had colors they had orange and
white the yellow and white had a sky
blue and white they had the light on
whites of course so I think I spent my
whole value on Air Force Ones that day
and I couldn't wait to get back home and
show everybody these Air Force was that
I had like you know got from Portland I
wasn't sure if they came out in New York
or not so I thought I had like a little
hidden gym that tour definitely was
eye-opening I got to see different types
of people celebrating embracing hip-hop
you know even down to the shoes the
early two-thousands was like a airforce
one boom I started seeing like he used
that pattern of customizing different
collaborations and you know even like
the basketball players Rasheed Wallace
he started playing in the eyes LeBron
had an airforce 124 a lot of guys had a
Air Force once you like the trust of one
it started being creative with it
changing the texture furrow you have cow
skin you have different type of letters
even out of time with they had one that
was see-through where you could just
actually see your foot inside of it I
hated those by the way one of my most
noted times aware about Air Force one
shoot I shot a video called can't let
you go and at the end of the video it
cuts to a song called Dan I remember
having some Air Force Ones that I had a
Dominican Republic flag placed on the
heel of my shoe
it just like exploded Dominicans
everywhere loved it even though that was
just such a small part a couple of
seconds in the video people connect this
event really well why don't why it's
probably my favorite pair because when
you first take them out of the box it's
like opening the gates of heaven because
it's like a glow it's like white and
bright
it can really fit this way in any kind
of outfit I've seen it all the way down
to our friends he had a wedding and
instead of shoes he made a six pair of
Air Force Ones with the wedding logo
instead of shoes so they all had on
tuxes with Air Force Ones and I was like
oh wow he got the wedding Air Force was
like you know me people also are part of
what keep it going to the off-white
subversion bit those were examples of
collaborations with a shoe that's
already what it is but what can they do
to make it more than it is I think those
are the things that help it stay afloat
and stay around the shoes it's been
around and it went through all different
points just classic the much we can say
about a classic but a classic